[Music]
welcome back to cbs this morning as the
delta variant sweeps across the country
we're taking a closer look at the
so-called breakthrough cases people who
get covid after receiving a vaccine
research shows it's extremely rare for
breakthrough cases to lead to
hospitalizations or death according to
the cdc out of 168 million people
vaccinated only about 1500 have died of
the virus that's a tiny fraction of one
percent our lead national correspondent
david begno joins us from lafayette
louisiana with more david good morning
anthony good morning
99.9 percent of people who've been
vaccinated do not and have not gotten
seriously ill or died from covid it's
extremely rare but listen it's happened
and it continues to happen and if it
happens to your family it's devastating
even if you're the only one so this
morning we're going to tell one of those
rare stories and give you all the
necessary context to understand how many
people are being affected like this
i'm not feeling well
tara mosley read to us what would be
some of her daughter's final words
my legs are turning black over the
course of the next few days angel would
describe her pain in detail through text
messages
as she lay alone at home and later in
the hospital
my lungs are clogged up with mucus and
blood on jail battled covid and
pneumonia in a new orleans hospital her
mother was only allowed to see her very
briefly so i went in and i prayed with
her and i had to show her that you know
we love her you know it's like angel we
love you
and
at that moment she shared a tear who
shed a tear
angel did she did
that same day july 25th angel died she
was 33 years old i just tested positive
for covert 19
while being vaccinated when angel
initially told her mother and her sister
that she had tested positive for covid
she said that she was vaccinated which
means that she is considered to be a
breakthrough case
now according to cdc data breakthrough
cases make up less than one percent of
all the coveted cases
of the more than 168 million americans
who have been fully vaccinated around 8
000 have been hospitalized or died of
covet and that is about point zero zero
five percent there will be people who
watch this story who say
she got vaccinated and she died
i would still say to them still be
fascinated because
her weight played a lot in it did the
doctor
ever speak to you about her weight and
that being a factor he did he did
something so he
been said she's a large person
her heart could not pump like it should
have been pumping the cdc says that
people with certain comorbidities are
more at risk for having severe symptoms
of covid19 which among them are obesity
chronic kidney and heart disease asthma
and cancer right now the majority of
cases what we're seeing positive with
cova 19 are the unvaccinated period cbs
news medical contributor dr david agus
says that vaccines are stopping people
from getting seriously ill and that
nearly everyone who has died after being
vaccinated has had some type of serious
underlying medical condition it's very
important for every single person who's
been vaccinated to know if you have
other medical conditions
the vaccine doesn't protect from those
becoming an issue or causing a problem
while the vaccines may give you some
protection
it's not enough to overcome the medical
issues or the lack of a very strong
immune system unfortunately anjel's
mother wanted to assure us that her
daughter took the virus seriously and
she wanted all of her friends and her
family to get vaccinated that's nice
that's a beautiful color too
angel was a budding entrepreneur she
owned brave beautique in new orleans
which is a store that specializes in
clothes for plus-sized women
inside angel's bright colored clothing
lines the walls
outside there has been a growing
memorial
if she were here right now what would
she want you to say
keep her business going because that was
hers that was her baby that was her
dream
i know she really wanted some people to
know to actually that's to be vaccinated
to still
mess up
you know is very imperative that we
still mess up
angel was buried over the weekend her
mother buried her in one of the dresses
that was sold at her store and angelle's
mom tells us she plans to keep that
store
up and running
one more thing before we go the leading
health officer here in louisiana said
just on friday that
100 people here in louisiana have died
after being fully vaccinated 23 within
the last week but he made this point he
said the median age of people who are
those breakthrough cases and getting
really sick and dying the median age is
74 years old and the vast majority of
those people
all have pretty severe underlying
conditions
gail
that's good to remember thank you david